in 1980 Stephen King published one of
his most disturbing stories a novella
called the mist the story got even more
disturbing when filmmaker Frank Darabont
wrote a new ending for his 2007 movie
adaptation the film's final twist
devastated audiences and it still
traumatized as people today here's what
it all means so considering this movie's
over 10 years old let's do a quick recap
so we're all on the same page the mist
tells the story of a dad named David and
his son Billy who get caught inside a
supermarket when a mysterious and
dangerous mist engulfs a small town in
Maine over the course of the film
we learn a few things the mist is full
of horrors which include deadly
tentacles and giant wasps and
pterodactyls we also learned that one of
the stores patrons Amanda Dumfries
carries a gun but before we skip to the
end there's one important moment that we
need to touch on before all the monsters
show up but after the parking lot is
filled with fog everybody agrees to stay
inside except for one unnamed woman
played by Melissa McBride she's a mom
who left her kids at home to do some
quick grocery shopping but with the
world falling apart she can't sit around
twiddling her thumbs
she's got to get back to her kids
several people tried to stop her but she
won't hear it and when she asked for
help everybody goes quiet teary-eyed and
disgusted she curses the group and she
strides into the mist having faith she
can get home in one piece it's a
nerve-wracking and heartbreaking moment
and one will need to file away for
future reference this moment comes
around full circle and hammers some
themes down hard eventually after the
mist starts belching up monsters
tentacles and tons of baby spiders
neighborhood nutjob mrs. Carmody a
bloodthirsty bible-thumper who thinks
the end times are nigh
starts gathering followers who oppose
our hero David and his allies attempts
to stay smart and survive during a
crisis suffice it to say this whole mist
thing is pretty bad news guys eventually
the survivors inside the supermarket
begin to turn on each other
Lord of the Flies style a small group of
allies join David and Billy as they
escape from the store in the hopes that
whatever's lurking in the mist isn't as
bad as the horror of human beings that
they're worse
several of them are picked off by killer
bugs but the surviving members david
billy and three others named amanda dan
and irene pile into a car and drive into
the fog but not before david grabs
Amanda's gun as they drive down the road
they see toppled telephone poles wrecked
cars and a school bus savaged by spiders
they find the webbed up body of David's
dead wife watch an enormous Lovecraftian
creature lumber by and no matter how far
they drive the mist stretches on forever
eventually they run out of gas and as
they hear the monsters outside they make
a decision a bullet is better than a bug
David checks the gun sees there are only
four bullets for five people and does
the deed he kills everyone in the car
including his son David is the only one
left alive howling like a wounded animal
then he starts begging for the monsters
to finish him off
but his despair deepens when seconds
later a military convoy rumbles out of
the Mist adding insult to injury david
seized vehicles full of survivors
including Melissa McBride and her kids
the mist clears and David is left
screaming in pain if only he'd waited a
few more seconds his son would still be
alive
[Music]
and on that cheery note the film fades
to black if you couldn't tell by the end
of the film the mist doesn't think very
highly of mankind it shares a worldview
with movies like Night of the Living
Dead and John Carpenter's The Thing
according to the mist people are prone
to paranoia and distrust and will turn
on each other when things go south but
at the same time the movie is ultimately
a message about the power of hope and
what happens when Hope disappears
speaking with Yahoo Entertainment Frank
Darabont explained the mist works as a
companion piece with his first feature
the Shawshank Redemption
if Shawshank is the movie about the
value of hope then the mist becomes a
movie about the danger of hopelessness
so in the 94 classic Andy Dufresne hangs
on to hope and escapes from prison
because it comes down to a simple choice
really busy live but in the midst
instead of getting busy living David and
his companions do the other one while
Andy keeps the faith and finds freedom
David gives up and loses everything when
salvation was so close and this is where
Melissa McBride's character comes back
in this mom marched into the fog to
rescue her kids even though everyone
else was scared and tried to stop her
she never let go of hope and as a result
she saved her children David on the
other hand fell into despair and lost
his son's life so what's the big moral
of the Mist even if life feels like a
never-ending nightmare be like that mom
because you never know when the mist
will fade away both the novella and
movie versions of the mist are excellent
but they radically different comes to
the ending while the film goes in a
decidedly dark direction King's novella
is much more ambiguous in fact the
author actually leaves his readers with
some hope that things will work out for
David and his crew team David escapes
the supermarket but instead of
committing mass suicide David turns on
the radio and thinks he hears a voice
say the word Harford encouraged he
believes Hartford Connecticut might be a
safe zone and he heads in that direction
the novella ends with David narrating
these final lines I'm going to bed now
but first I'm going to kiss my son and
whisper two words in his ear two words
that sound a bit
like one of them is Hartford the other
is hope and that's where the book ends
hinting that maybe team David is going
to be okay
obviously Darabont decided to traumatize
moviegoers but Stephen King was totally
okay with the movie's new ending when
Darabont asked for king's opinion on the
nihilistic finale the author gave him
two thumbs up King even famously
declared that quote anybody who reveals
the last five minutes of this film
should be hung from their neck until
dead okay
we really hope he doesn't watch this
video check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]